but so then
so okay so the the first question the
first idea of
these models of ours is space is made of
these
you know connected sort of atoms of
space the next idea
is space is all there is there's nothing
except for this space
so in traditional ideas in physics
people have said there's space it's kind
of a background
and then there's mata all these
particles electrons all these other
things
which exist in space right
but in this model one of the key ideas
is there's nothing except space
so in other words everything that has
that exists in the universe
is a feature of this hyper graph so how
can that possibly be well
the way that works is that there are
certain
uh structures in this hypergraph where
you say that
little twisty knotted thing we don't
know exactly how this works yet but but
we we have sort of idea about how it
works mathematically
this sort of twisted knotted thing
that's the core of an electron
this thing over there that has this
different form that's something else
so the different peculiarities of the
structure of this
graph are the very things
that uh we think of as the particles
inside the space but
in fact it's just the property of
features of space mind-blowing first of
all that
it's mind-blowing and we'll probably
talk in its simplicity and beauty
yes i think it's very beautiful i mean
this is i mean
okay so but that's space and then
there's another concept we didn't really
kind of mention
but you thinking of computation as a
like a transformation let's talk about
time in a second let's let's
just let's just i mean on the subject of
space that you know there's this
question of kind of
what you know there's this idea there is
this hyper graph
it represents space and it represents
everything that's in space the features
of that hyper graph
you can say certain features in this
part we do know
certain features of the hypergraph
represent the presence of energy for
example
or the presence of mass or momentum and
we know what the
features of the hypergraph that
represent those things are but it's all
just the same hypograph
so one thing you might ask is you know
if you just look at this hypergraph and
you say
and we're going to talk about sort of
what the hypergraph does but if you say
you know how much of what's going on in
this hypograph
is things we know and care about like
particles and
atoms of electrons and all this kind of
thing and how much is just
the background of space so it turns out
so far as in one rough estimate of this
or everything that we care about in the
universe is only
one part in 10 to 120 of what's actually
going on
the vast majority of what's happening is
purely things that maintain the
structure of space
that in other words that the things that
are the features of space
that are the things that we consider
notable like the presence of particles
and so on
that's a tiny little piece of froth on
the top of all this activity
that mostly is just intended to you know
mostly i can't say intended there's no
intention here
that just maintains the structure of
space
let me let me load that in it's uh
it just makes me feel so good as a human
being
well to be the froth on the one in the
10 to the 120 or something of
well and also just humbling um
how in this mathematical framework
how much work needs to be done on the
infrastructure
right yes our universe right to maintain
the infrastructure of our universe is a
lot of work
we are we are merely writing little tiny
things on top of that infrastructure
you